[Music]
good evening I'm Alexander Rose I'm the
executive director at the long now
foundation I'm really excited about
tonight's talk I think it was actually
Stuart and I were watching the landing
live when we both realized we knew Adam
steltzner from long time ago in
Sausalito so it's so great to have a
local person speaking in this series
couple couple just announcements one is
that when we do talks here you've
probably already noticed that there's
bars and you can get it drink and bring
it to your seat so it's kind of a
prototype of our salon project that's
going to be happening in Fort Mason in a
way and the other thing that you may not
have noticed because I've failed to
announce it is that we do receptions on
the mezzanine and there's more bars and
you can keep talking about all the
awesome stuff that you listen to at
these talks so it's a it's really fun
venue in that sense the other
announcement that we have is we just
booked our January seminar to bookend
the last ten years of these talks and if
some of you remember that the very first
one was by Brian Eno and he will be
speaking again January 21st with Danny
Hillis one of the cofounders of long now
and the father of the clock project that
I work on so that's exciting and we I
think actually this month or next month
is our actual ten-year anniversary so
thank you all for coming
just one more time it's show of hands
anyone here from the see the 2003 Brian
Eno talk almost 50 people or so nice
cool so as many of you know we do a long
short before these talks and this
particular one was inevitable that we
had to do the seven minutes of Terror I
know many of you have probably seen it
there you will see even more of it with
some live data mixed in
as part of adam's talk but there's no
better introduction to Adam and the
amazingness that happened with the Mars
program than this so enjoy when people
look at it it looks crazy that's a very
natural thing sometimes when we look at
it it looks crazy it is the result of
reasoned engineering thought
but it still looks crazy the top of the
atmosphere down to the surface
it takes a seven minutes it takes 14
minutes or so for the signal from the
spacecraft to make it to earth that's
how far Mars is away from us so when we
first get word that we've touched off of
the atoms
vehicle surface
[Music]
entry descent landing also known as EDL
to refer to as a seven minutes of Terror
because we've got literally seven
minutes to get from the top of the
atmosphere to the surface of Mars going
from 13,000 miles an hour to zero and
perfect sequence perfect choreography
perfect timing and the computer has to
do it all by itself if any one thing
doesn't work just right it's game over
we slam into the atmosphere develop so
much aerodynamic drag power efficient it
feeds up and it glows like the sugars of
yourself 1600 degrees
during entry and vehicles not all the
slowing down violently through the
atmosphere but also we are guiding like
an airplane to be able to land in a very
narrow from screen space this is one of
the biggest challenges that we're facing
and one that we had never attempted on
Mars Mars is actually really hard to
slow down because it has just enough
atmosphere that you have to deal with it
otherwise it will destroy your
spacecraft on the other hand it doesn't
have enough atmosphere to finish the job
we're still going about a thousand miles
now so at that point we use a parachute
the parachute is the largest and
strongest supersonic parachute that
we've ever built to date it has to be
able to withstand 65,000 pounds of force
even though the parachute itself only
weighs about 100 pounds
when it opens up that fast it's a neck
snapping nine genes at that point we
have to get that heat shield off it's
like a big lens cap blocking our view of
the ground to the radar the radar has to
take just the right altitude and
velocity measurements at just the right
time or the rest of the landing sequence
won't work this big huge parachute that
we've got it'll only slow us down to
about 200
and that's not slow enough to land so we
have no choice you gotta cut it off and
come down in rockets once we turn those
rocket motors on we don't do something
weird you're gonna smack right back into
the parachute so the first thing we do
is make this really radical dead bird
fly off to the side diverting away from
the parachute killing our horizontal
velocity and our vertical velocity
getting you over moving straight up and
down so it can look at the surface with
its radars and see where we're going to
land and we head straight down to the
bottom of a crater right beside a six
kilometre hyah
get those rocket into the two quotes the
green because if we were to send Paul
simply there are engines all the way to
the ground and essentially create this
massive dust cloud that dust cloud could
then go and land on the rover they could
damage mechanisms and academic
instrument so the way we solve that
problem is by using the sky cream 20
metres above the surface we have to
lower the rover below us on a tether
that's 21 feet long and then gently
deposited on its wheels on the string
as the rover touches down and is now on
the ground the descent stage it's in a
collision course with a roller we must
cut the bridle immediately and fly the
descent stage to a safe distance from
the
[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart brand from a
long now foundation that has to count as
one of the best trailers for a movie
that hasn't actually happened yet
I have one Mars story 1976 I was working
for Jerry Brown in the sort of the the
retinue that went around with him and at
that time the Viking landing the first
landing on Mars was about to happen and
we trudged down to Jet Propulsion
Laboratory and watched the proceedings
and Carl Sagan was there and everything
and then we got the first image back
that showed the Landers foot on Mars
cheering and carrying on Carl Sagan was
over a little set next to a model of the
lander and here come the television guys
saying so Carl Carl do you think there's
life on Mars and Carl says big smile
there is now our next speaker is part of
the life on Mars Adam steltzner
[Applause]
this is Mars for eons its captivated our
attention
we've looked up at the night sky from
before we had an understanding of what
was in the night sky and we've seen
something of a little bigger a little
redder a little fuzzier than the rest of
the stars in the celestial sphere we
wondered whether it was alive
when we got our early telescopes we
looked up at it and we saw that it was
it had canals and roadways landing
strips we saw civilization then we got
better telescopes and we realized that
those features were in fact just natural
features on the surface of Mars but we
never shook the thought that maybe Mars
was alive and that's maybe
understandable because are we really
alone in this universe are we alone in
our solar system could our nearest
neighbor Harbor life so about 10 years
ago NASA asked the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory to construct a mission to
help answer that question they wanted us
to put a rover on the surface of Mars
and not just anywhere on the surface of
Mars but here this is the Gale Crater on
the equator of Mars
it's a massive crater 90 miles across
about the size of the Big Island of
Hawaii in the center is a huge mountain
Mount sharp standing 15,000 feet above
the crater floor higher than anything in
the continental US and the Rockies in
the Sierras they asked us to put a rover
right down there sort of between the
canonical rock in a hard place between
the credit rim and that massive mountain
this is a pretty cool image it's
actually an image constructed of orbital
data taken from the Mars Reconnaissance
Orbiter science satellite in orbit
around
Mars those are digital images that have
been rendered true to Elevation and
constructed into a digital elevation map
so this is actually what that creator
would look like if you were able to fly
an aircraft at about sixty or seventy
thousand feet above the surface that
image is used to keep me up at night
used to make me feel sick to my stomach
because of the challenge of getting down
there safely if you go into Mars you
have to do four things if you're taking
anything bigger than a breadbox or
smaller than a house you have to do
these four things in orders of magnitude
you hit the atmosphere going about ten
thousand miles an hour or so if you're
coming from Earth heading to Mars that's
how fast you'll be mmm fifteen ten we
did thirteen thousand three hundred 26
miles an hour when we slammed into the
atmosphere that's fast enough that
there's enough kinetic energy enough
energy of motion to vaporize the entire
spacecraft can't let that happen
so we wrap the spacecraft in a special
shell a narrow shell and it's a carbon
fiber structure generic aerospace
structure but coated with a very special
material that resists the heat that
smolders but does not burn and allows us
to reject that kinetic energy to the
atmosphere essentially we burn a hole in
the sky on Mars when we hit that
atmosphere that slows us down a lot it
slows us down to about a thousand miles
an hour or so the specifics for
curiosity are about eight hundred miles
an hour not slow enough open up a
parachute as Anita one of my teammates
mentioned in that video it's the world's
largest supersonic parachute that takes
us down to a couple hundred miles an
hour as Tom mentioned that's certainly
not slow enough to land on the surface
of Mars and so we go to Rockets now in
general that set of things happens has
to happen because Mars doesn't have
enough atmosphere to handle the
parachute that will slow you down
all the way to the surface and so you're
left with going to propulsion and then
depending on how good your prop system
is if it's throttle able or not if
you've got good sensor
that are sensing the ground you need to
deploy or employ a final touchdown
system something to take out the last
one to ten miles an hour that last sort
of gentle embrace kiss with the Martian
surface this is the old vaudeville joke
right it's not the fall that kills you
it's the landing even though the kinetic
energy of that final touchdown for MSL
for curiosity the rover was less than
three one millionth of a percent of the
arrival kinetic energy it was in some in
some sense that which we struggled with
most but just to get down and fit
between the rock and the hard place
we're going to have to innovate starting
at the top because if you here's another
image of the of the Gale Crater this is
shaded relief orange is high blue is low
you can see Mount sharp in the center
and the crater rim on the outside what
we've done is we've overlaid on that the
landing ellipse is the uncertainty
footprints we call them ellipses because
they're ellipsoidal of all of the
successful us missions to the surface of
Mars which essentially are all the
successful mission suit you to the
surface of Mars there are unsuccessful
Russian missions and they're
unsuccessful US missions but the ones
that made it look like that then you can
see over time starting with viking and
moving forward we've done better some of
that was based on our ability to
navigate between the planets so the
first reduction is improvements in in
planetary navigation and then that
occurs there's a big jump between Mars
Pathfinder in 97 and 2004 spear and
opportunity and that's a different sort
of a quantum change in how we do inter
interplanetary navigation using quasars
fixed known fixed locations in the star
in the sky in the celestial sphere radar
radio sources that are well known
- better triangulate rather than just
our own position and the position of Sun
but that only does so good and to land
down in there on that flat blue spot we
were going to have to do on next quanta
and to do that we use that guided entry
we took our symmetric entry body and we
displaced its center of mass which meant
it flied it's sort of a cocked or canted
angle and flying thusly it developed
lifts so we took that lift and we
steered it side to side up and down to
accommodate differences in the
atmosphere of Mars which we never really
know about on the day that we land so if
we show up in the atmosphere is less
than we think we push the lift down and
we drag ourselves deeper in the
atmosphere and we get more molecules to
run into if there's more molecules than
we anticipated we pull ourselves out of
the atmosphere a little bit that allowed
us to get down there unfortunately when
we were gonna get down to the bottom
there we weren't gonna be landing just
any old Rover we're gonna be landing the
world's biggest Rover ever here is a
family portrait of the Rovers that we've
put on the surface of Mars in 97 the
Sojourner Rover a tiny little mission
the Mars Pathfinder was the name of the
mission the rover's name was Sol Turner
usually there's a difference between the
mission name and the and the name of the
vehicles Pathfinder is very important
because as Stuart mentioned we first
went to the surface of Mars in 1976 and
we went there to try and find life
that's an ambitious question to try and
answer on one fell swoop and we didn't
or we didn't in a way that we could
consider conclusive certainly and we
didn't go back we didn't go back for 20
years we didn't go back for 20 years
because well the price of Viking in well
the great thing about 70s is I can't
tell you what the price of Viking is
because we didn't keep track
that's called the good old days you know
space race get to the high ground really
cold war an active war wrapped in a
cloak of civility so we didn't keep
track but if you go back down you sort
of reconstruct what the costs were it's
probably five to ten billion dollars and
that's a notable investment
I can't wait for later to figure out
whether that's a what that means but in
1990s the then NASA Administrator Dan
Goldin said what if we embrace increased
risk and look for a strategy to explore
a greatly reduced cost
that was the Mars Pathfinder mission
it wasn't pathfinding away to Mars we
knew how to get to Mars it was path
finding a new lower cost way of getting
to Mars and it did that it put that
little rover on the surface of Mars for
350 million dollars and no matter what
you think we spent on on Viking three
hundred fifty million dollars is at
least an order of magnitude less buoyed
by that success we vowed to go back
every time we could it ends up being due
to the celestial mechanics that's every
26 months so we did we had some fits and
starts and then in 2004 we were
successful with the spear and
opportunity
twin rovers two Rovers on the opposite
sides of the planet Spirit and
Opportunity are their names that's one
of them I can't tell you which one it is
because they're twins but they were very
very important because they showed us
that liquid water then on the surface of
Mars and we know from Earth that where
there's life liquid water is not far
from it and where there is no liquid
water to be found at any state at any
time we don't find life so that was
fantastic
it helps with this key question of is
there life on Mars but spear an
opportunity left some questions
unanswered they couldn't
tell us some important things was the
water salty was it was it sweet was it
[Music]
acid-base in short was that aqueous
environment that ancient aqueous
environment of Mars was it habitable
well in comes curiosity she's packed to
the brim with all the equipment that
you'd need to answer that question the
problem is she's difficult to land she's
big buy Rovers times she's big buy
automobile sizes you know human scales
she's large and we really struggled with
how we might land her over the course of
about seven years ending really in 2003
we were struggling with the question of
how to land the big rover which is what
we referred to it and we looked at
airbags we'd used those to land spear an
opportunity and and a Mars Pathfinder
they it ends up being that that that
airbags scale poorly as the mass of the
vehicle goes up and there's no fabrics
known to human beings that are strong
enough no fibers that are strong enough
that we can make a fabric out of that we
could have airbags we looked at legged
Landers imagine Viking and you just
stick a Rover on top well in those fits
and starts getting to Mars in 2004
between 97 and 2004 we lost a mission
called the Mars Polar Lander which was a
legged Lander and as we went through the
failure analysis of that weary mind it
ourselves of some of the fragilities or
some of the risks associated with those
kinds of legged Landers they end up
being tippy they don't tolerate slopey
terrains very well and you put a one-ton
Rover on top of it you have compounded
the problem so they were out so we
looked at trying to solve that problem
by spreading out the legs adding more
legs making a big flat
Skeeter bug and belly-flopping
unfortunately the propulsion systems in
the valley
it's got toxic and frequently explosive
fuel exploding on touchdown super poor
form and so we have to
armored the the belly of the beast and
when we start to armor it the weight
goes up and up and up and eventually we
cannot launch it so in the September of
2003 we got everybody together who had
ever worked on anything like this and we
went back into a brainstorming session
because none of these methods that we
had been working on or were bearing
fruit
we vomited out onto BigTable every idea
we'd ever had we cut and pasted
collaging them together trying to see if
we could interpret a new way of doing it
that was different or adjacent or better
than the ways we've done it before out
of that room came something we called at
the time direct placement rapidly took
the name sky crane and we knew two
things when we left that room one we had
a solution that we believed in for very
real engineering reasons and two we had
a solution that would impeach our
credibility
every time we opened our mouth in fact
it was my job to open my mouth most
frequently I wonder why that was the
case I may be personally inclined to do
so and I developed a little pithy saying
that I would start a conversation with
in order to try and retain some shred of
credibility that saying goes like this
great works and great folly may be
indistinguishable at the outset
it's kind of perfect right if it's
really revolutionary if it's really
different
it'll look crazy problem is that crazy
also looks crazy and so we are left
personally in the team myself team of
about fifty at the core with the nagging
feature nagging question are we
convincing ourselves of this is this
really crazy and we're really just all
along for the ride what compounds that
is the fact you can't test this system
you cannot test it here on earth the
differences in gravity the differences
in the atmosphere all mean that there's
no way we can construct a test vehicle
to prove whether we were crazy or not
all we're left with is analysis first in
pens and paper later ones and zeros this
here is a simulation one of millions of
computer simulations we've put all the
physics we could think of into this
model and we're looking asking how it
works in fact right here we're landing
the rover on a thirty five degree slope
that is so slippery that the rover
cannot Rove and yet we can land her so
this made us feel very confident
unfortunately this kind of analysis only
tells you the answers to the things that
you ask of it when prior to landing
people would ask me what is the thing
you're most worried about I would answer
very truthfully the thing I don't know
to be worried about I have a long list
of things to be worried about we go
through that long list we work the
bejesus out of every single one of those
things until we prove to ourselves that
were satisfied and we accept the risks
associated with each one of those the
thing you fear is not the thing you're
talking about it's the thing you're not
talking about the thing you don't know
to have on there and that's not in that
computer model so it all came down to
August 5th for us here on the west coast
Sunday 2000
twelve last year 10:30 at night and this
is how it happened it will report Center
interface at this time it'll be it
pressurizing the ocean system to
increase the thrust of the system
I'll use that for all the Venusian
atmosphere we're about two vehicles just
recorded via tones that it has started
guided entry deceleration
we just have parachute deploy around
Mach 1.7
Paris boy we are decelerating detailed
steps has separated where we found the
ground man we're down to 90 meters per
second at an altitude of 6.5 kilometers
setting standing by for backshell
separation
we are in power Dwight
[Applause]
for an altitude of one poverty
anybody perspective decorating started
Hinkel know if you remain strong
touchdown confirmed
[Applause]
[Applause]
so so that was a good night infinitely
preferable to the alternate feet which
awaited us on Mars that evening I know
for myself and I know that for many of
the of the team that the numbers that
come back that tell you that the
vehicles done its job that you're safe
all require the front of my noggin to
decompose them and figure them out and
that a much more visceral experience
that we had accomplished what we saw out
to is found in these these are the first
images of a new place for us in our
solar system from the left this is
looking at the front of the rover
through what's called our hazard cams
with the lens covers removed nice clean
image of Mount sharp in the distance and
the I meant it to the right your left my
right and a black sand dunes between
Mount sharp and us in the center is the
Molly image from one of our science
cameras with its dust cover it's clear
dust cover still on it covered in the
red oxide rich dust giving a very
beautifully red toned view in color for
the first time of this new place on Mars
and the leftmost image for you is in
fact the very first image of this new
place we had this D this orbiter that I
mentioned the Mars Reconnaissance
Orbiter over flying us as we landed and
we had a data stream the telemetry that
you saw us reacting to in the control
room all came through that spacecraft
and that link was very important because
if we were to wink out or disappear or
blow up we wanted to be able to
reconstruct or hopefully reconstruct how
and why that happened so we were using
that data link once we were on the
ground we were losing that link and we
thought we might just have just enough
time to get one image
so we chose this image it's out the rear
hazard care camps these are fish eye
lenses low on the rover that are
designed to help it when it rose around
we took that image because we were
hoping that we just might see the plume
associated with the impact crater when
the descent stage flies off to a safe
distance and crashes if you squint you
can see that that is in fact what that
is so it was a really good night
everything worked on the numbers we
nailed it that blue light blue is the
ellipse the green diamond the red X and
the black cross are variously the
spacecraft's belief in where it was
where we thought it would be during the
when we hit the Martian atmosphere and
where it ended up actually being and
they're all right in within a city block
as far as getting to Mars is concerned
that's worth barking about and after
landing we haven't just sat there we've
moved we've done other things all of us
landing guys got fired pink-slipped
we have gone off to do other things but
evidently there's a whole mission that
starts when our job is done and folks
have driven the rover and and ask
questions and gotten some pretty
incredible answers in fact we are about
halfway through the mission and already
we've answered one of the key questions
that curiosity was sent to ask was the
ancient environment on Mars habitable
through taking cores powdering into
drilling into the into the surface of
Mars and bringing out powdery material
and distributing it to a set of science
instruments on board we have an answer
and the answer is yes if there was life
on Mars or if there is life on Mars that
ancient aqueous waterborne environment
would have supported it it has a right
by the salinity had alright right water
activity I don't understand what that is
to support life that's kind of profound
so she's there she's um doing great
science she as the president's science
adviser said 2,000 pounds of American
ingenuity but I'm left with a question
why do we do this you know is it a why
is it a particularly practical thing for
us to be doing this it took you know
it's 10 years 37 states 10,000 people
two and a half billion dollars secure
idea it's a practical what is sometimes
I even start to get tripped up as to
what is practical I can tell you some
things that I know to be practical the
737-700 is practical this is Burbank
Airport I can get V a-- the air stairs
onto burbank as i love that you know
just like a bus it's literally like a
bus and I go down to the Johnson Space
Flight Center in Houston fairly often
and that's a trip that I do in three
hours when my mother was young it
probably would have taken her three days
and when her mother was young it
probably would have taken her three
weeks so air travel is convenient
practical it's had a profound effect on
our society and yet if you look at the
early exploration of what flights about
it doesn't appear very practical it
doesn't appear that it doesn't really
appear that it had promise of being
particularly practical I can't see the
allure it's more
it's more a drive sort of an impractical
despite the impracticality of it early
attempts at aviation the early attempt
to explore the heavens was in Juris
frequently humiliating and unfortunately
often fatal but we kept trying
unreasonably and eventually we succeeded
even though for many years
aviation would still be a very risky
proposition so it's not practical
necessarily we can't be guaranteed that
it's practical there may be practical
outcomes from it but we don't do it for
that reason is it for the science
science questions now this is an image
of Times Square on Monday morning the
sixth at 1:30 in the morning
on the East Coast it was Monday morning
at 1:30 in the morning when we landed
Times Square there's a few thousand
people there I'm told it was a lightning
storm now are there a few thousand
people sitting on a Monday morning at
1:30 in a lightning storm at Time Square
watching the diamond screen because
they're dying to know about the pH and
salinity of the ancient primordial
environment on Mars I don't think so
or at least not just that it might be
akin to when thousands of people watch
an athlete to see if they can run a set
distance one hundredths of a second
faster than another athlete when we
explore we're actually asking questions
about ourselves as individuals as a
society as a people Neil Armstrong
actually hinted at it a bit when he
chose the words to stay when he stepped
foot on the moon one small step for a
man one giant leap for mankind he was
hinting that his act was bringing us
with him that his exploration was our
exploration that our society
our owl us with somehow being to quote
jebediah Springfield from The Simpsons
in bigint so exploration asks questions
like who are we how grand
are we what is our reach what questions
might we dare ask and believe we could
hope to get the answer so I don't think
exploration is practical but I do think
it is essential I think it is an
expression of our humanity in the same
way that we sing I'm not totally sure of
the utility of singing except that it
makes me very very happy
art architecture there are all sorts of
beautiful things almost all of the
beautiful things that we humans do are
considerably abstracted from their
obvious need that's one of the great
things that makes us us so we've got
great things in the nowadays in front of
us so Mars sample return it ends up
being that all the ingenuity you can
pack into a one-ton Rover does not match
the ingenuity sitting in this room
certainly sitting on this planet and so
to really answer the question about
whether Mars was alive or not we may
well have to bring a piece of at home
and I'm actually working on what might
be involved in doing that Europa the icy
moon of Jupiter's I'm not an
exobiologist but I drink beer with
exobiologist
it makes me feel like an exobiologist
sometimes and they tell me that one of
the key places one of the like number
one spot in our solar system that could
have existing life today is Europa
I certainly hope in this next few
decades we put a lander on the surface
to see what life may have up weld in
that ice and be present on the outside
surface Titan the moon of Saturn we know
that there are methane lakes a rich
organic compound methane Lakes the size
of Lake Superior on the surface of Titan
what else are in those compounds how
important might they have been in early
formulation of life these are questions
that we have in front of us these are
things we do with robots these are
things that I do with robots but if this
is such an essential human thing if this
is an essential expression of our
humanity it makes sense that humans also
would be physically involved and I think
they will be this is an image of a Mars
try a possible Mars transfer vehicle to
take humans to the surface of Mars it's
much harder to take humans than it is to
take a robot we designed curiosity to
withstand 15 G's on entry and that 15 g
pulse landed about lasted about 16
seconds or so that would kill a human
being in fact humans we've known since
the 50s are got a delicate
consumptive cranky they need water and
food they don't tolerate radiation very
much and there's a lot of radiation in
the universe outside of the magnetic
field in this planet that shelters us
from the streaming radiation from the
Sun it's a very nasty place it's
unconceivable cold or indescribable hot
bathed and radiation
it's unfriendly and keeping humans alive
and happy in that environment is a
challenge but I think we will do that
and you I think we'll see that happen in
the few decades from now it's hard to
predict with the way we do business
today it's quite expensive and those
expenses might be hard to choose to
accept if it were 50 50 billion dollars
people sometimes say when are we gonna
have humans on Mars I say well you know
when you when you start to see a 10 or
20 billion dollar a year surplus in the
federal budget it could happen anytime
what about colonization what about going
to stepped further there are folks who
propose colonizing the planets certainly
Mars is a very popular one and we could
imagine colonizing it in the near future
decades using current technology this is
an example of an image for Mars one the
folks about what that kind of colony
might look like personally I'm not sure
that's a colony that looks more like an
outpost there are places on earth that
we have explored but that we have not
chosen to really live an example might
be Antarctica this is actually another
outpost looks a lot like the previous
image but this is the Halle six station
for the British Antarctic expedition on
on an ice shelf and there are 14 people
who live there year-round and it blooms
up to let's say 50 or so that's not
really civilization and it's supported a
lot by by material and peace of people
from the places that are not like this
like the places that are like this but
so if we really imagine colonizing space
stretching out from this earth outside
we're going to need to go to places
where we can really live not that we can
just eat out a subsistence and that
means things like terraforming or world
ships this is a artist's rendition of a
possible terraformed Mars and and this
is a a world ship a ship that could be
moving or it could be stationary but
would have all of the attributes of our
planet in it or many of them the
important ones
a lot of people I talk to are attracted
to this as a cure for what ails this
world because we're going to be
overpopulated or because we're going to
pollute this planet or because we're not
going to be able to get our [ __ ]
together I think that that is a cop-out
I think that is short of thinking
because there are no skills necessary in
accomplishing either of these two goals
that are not those same skills required
to maintain balance and equilibrium here
on earth so I have lived in many houses
in my life some of them have been large
and some of them have been small but all
of them have been equally cluttered and
messy
the problem is not the size of my house
so when I think about space exploration
when I think about what it means in the
long the best thinking that I can do
brings me back here that the that we
learn like we do when we travel this
earth away from our homes new and
beautiful things that challenge our
minds expand our understanding but when
we return home we see it in a new way in
a better way in a deeper way I think
that's what exploration does for us I
think it is fundamentally human I think
it is essential but I don't think it
will solve the ills of this planet I
think that is for us to do here at home
thank you for your attention
have a seat yeah
Liam s that self-portrait of curiosity
was done oh I was hoping nobody would
notice we actually have five vehicles on
the surface of Mars a few camera
vehicles that take different images
actually so those are those are
composites of many many images we use
that's using the choosing a science
instrument actually the Mali the Mars
hand lens imager on the end of the
robotic arm it's made to have a very
wide focal length and be able to focus
very close up looking at microstructure
of rocks and also to be able to get
views up to a few meters away and so we
take images many images hundreds of
images and we we make a mosaic and so we
can choose if we want to to take the
images that eventually erase the arm and
that's what we do it's the easiest
because the arm shows up differently in
each of those images very much
differently in each of those images
because it's close to the imager and is
very difficult to rectify all that so we
choose it so that they're gone so it
looks like the camera vehicles taking
the image would be fun to they reproduce
that right here you have this Karen then
anyway Rob Carlson asks the surface of
Mars is like Clark's mixed with sand
earth bacteria found thousands feet deep
and ice and mud how deep do we drill to
find any surviving bacteria on Mars
that's a good question
one of the one of the fun things about
me is I well I'm willing to speculate on
things that I'm absolutely unqualified
to answer
so let me do that now um my
understanding from really just sitting
around in rooms with people who
understand this stuff and listening to
them to speak and having them ask me to
do stuff is that you know there's
certainly a rot whether it's called the
weathering rind you know about five
centimeters that is most eroded by
radiation from the Sun and oxidation
from the atmosphere what's the radiation
like on the surface of Mars um it is
substantially higher than the radiation
on earth I don't have it off the top of
my head but the exposure is several
orders of magnitude greater than I
showed a bar chart of it not something
we'd want to walk around in a spacey
super well you could walk around in a
spacesuit
if you know based on what we know today
if you were to take humans and and not
take countermeasures and you were to
take them and do the quickest trip to
Mars and back you'd give them over an
order of magnitude higher radiation dose
than the Department of Energy allows any
of its workers to see annually all right
so it would probably it may well have an
observable effect on their health now
you would take countermeasures you put
them in in water lined you use water as
insulation for the for for the radiation
and so you can do a lot of things to
knock that down it's not a place you can
walk around on shield air so to answer
the question you go I know that when you
get a five centimeters below the surface
you're into stuff that these thoughts to
be free from that constant weathering
bombardment and is the things that the
scientists are interested looking at
here back here on earth for signs of
biological activity so in that sense
they think they can get to some of it at
least within about five centimeters of
the surface
a lot of people here probably you saw
the movie are you seeing now some of the
IMAX theatres gravity yes
have you seen gravity unfortunately I
have not unfortunately fortunately
[Laughter]
fortunately I have a she lives that's
right
well now I don't see it am I about young
daughter 14 months old so I have not
seen a movie in four months
nor will for another two years right
nevertheless it's gravity's out there's
blowing people's minds that they get a
more regular sense of realities so
freaked out it's not even funny there's
something so primordial II alone about
spinning off into space
yes oh yes it's still news to a lot of
people it is quiet in space yeah
and so one of the you know shocking
effects of the movie is the horribly
violent things going on I don't hear
squat except why would we send people
anywhere in space is a open question
which now that you've had such good luck
with the robots it's an open question
why send people anywhere in space right
so that's a great one I feel even more
qualified to answer that one so I I do
for me at least personally it's I think
of what we do as being I'll get in
trouble for saying this akin to
performance aren't I mean it's a sort of
an essential expression of ourselves and
and so if it is such an expression of
humaneness having humans doing it makes
sense to me it's not it you know not
solely humans are you know tremendously
difficult to deal with and and expensive
to deal with but you could imagine
exploring with human beings as part of
it absolutely because we're doing it
because we're human
so what are the things that happen that
you were describing in the sequence of
missions is price goes down
acceptability of risk goes up yep
and that then raises the question of
manned emissions and there's lots of
people who seem to be willing to
volunteer for a one-way trip to Mars
and do you have an opinion on that yeah
that's I do and that's I think a very
very interesting question part of me
thinks we might run into like a wall of
exploration I fear it um it goes like
this I argue that most of the people who
got in boats and and paddled over the
horizon drowned we didn't know about
that really because they didn't come
back and but life was cheap you know I
recently read a great book Death Valley
in 49 which is Louis Wilden man Manley's
account of his life and to hear him
discuss seven people dying in a you know
boat with 200 passengers on a day and
being most interested is how they
wrapped the bodies and slide them off
boards into the sea not that seven of
200 people died in a day tells you how
differently we react today then even
just a hundred years ago or two hundred
years ago or a thousand years ago here's
the question I have that I wonder mmm
it goes to let's say Elon Musk Elon Musk
wants to go to to land on Mars I I love
that right it's a kid I mean you know
it's a little bit like suicide I mean
which which which also strangely and I'd
offer Bridgend going up right right but
you know the the the no it's a terminal
event right and our society doesn't
accept suicide we make it illegal we'll
lock you up if you try and do it so I'm
intrigued as to the societal response to
what it will mean if somebody says I'm
gonna go do this thing and I acknowledge
that the vast likelihood is that I will
die but I'm going to do it because I
want to do it and it's interesting and
maybe it furthers you humanity I hope
that we don't reach a point where we are
where
what's gonna sound weird or I do hope I
could imagine us reaching a point where
we value human life so much that we'd
have a hard time allowing that to happen
and then what would that mean for us you
know is that a good thing or a bad thing
I don't know so that's my reaction you
mentioned Elon Musk and as an example
there are many people who might have
money and want to go do that
so there's SpaceX doing pretty
impressive stuff
grasshopper 740 744 meter flight filmed
by the quadcopter mmm-hmm
I'll go run out and YouTube that because
that's awesome do you think the
privatization of that aspect of space is
a good thing absolutely do ABS love the
privatization of space it breaks up the
status quo it educates it disrupts it
creates chaos what comes of that will be
better whether it will be better exactly
in the way that the people who are doing
that disruption think it will be I don't
know it doesn't matter right the system
is being agitated and new variants of
genetic right we're we're mixing genes
we're finding new sub Optimum's so
you're within NASA yes I work at the Jet
Propulsion Laboratory which is a federal
FFRDC federally funded research and
development center there are lots of
those they're like Sandia National Labs
Lawrence Livermore National Labs you
know there are DoD and do labs there is
a single NASA FFRDC and that's the DIA
propulsion laboratory what that means is
I'm a Caltech employee hireable and
fireball will but we have a contract
with the federal government to do a lot
at least 80% or so something like that
of NASA work now within NASA be right
next to NASA right yeah and so the
privatization is starting to happen I
mean for a while we've kind of counting
on Russians for a whole lot right and
now there's these other players how does
that play out in terms of what you see
within JPL and within NASA well for
instance just I mean to stay with Ilan's
organization which by the way is a
fantastic organization and I think he's
a very bright man
you know the Falcon Heavy may offer the
capacity to throw three times as much
mass at the surface of Mars for a third
of the cost currently a launch vehicle
ride to Mars is approximately 300
million dollars it's a little bit of
money it's actually a lot of money and
if that were a hundred million dollars
and you put three times the mass that
may actually be a game-changer as to the
kinds of things that we try to do right
the approaches that we take we might be
consumptive with mass and use lower tech
drinks because if mass is no longer you
know a hundred thousand dollars a kilo
it's a thousand dollars kilo so it could
well be a game-changer Andrew Pfister
asks are there any interesting
improvements in rover landing strategy
for future missions how would you land a
man vehicle on Mars how would you landed
three times heavier thing the sense I
got is this and it's one of the things
that appeared in there in the profile in
New Yorker is that if against all
apparent odds the sky crane works it is
a system with the future you know it was
funny I have a friend of mine who is
actually the project manager of the of
the mission who used to joke with me as
we were doing the development they said
Adam how does it feel to design the last
entry descent and landing system ever
and I don't I don't think you by the way
it felt really freakin cool but I don't
think that I don't think he's right
there isn't one size fits all when we
look at the sky crane we see that it
actually is relatively scalable right
the architecture is completely scalable
you could ask if it's scalable at a
piece part level and some of those piece
parts you know we have a hard time
scaling down like for instance we have
eight engines they have a certain thrust
they have a certain minimum throttle if
you get too light you need to go to four
those engines but you can't actually get
the dynamic range of throttling that we
need out of a single engine that's why
we do two pairs of two and turn one off
and so you might have to develop new
engines to go down but architectural
either things scales all over the place
it's awesome it does really lots of
great things one of which is it's the
first actual closed-loop Lander you know
when you want a legged land or lands on
the surface it's actually quite hard the
control systems are relatively slow
witted compared to the stiffness of the
legs and and all of these systems are
thrust vector control that is to say if
I want to go in this direction i tilted
the vehicle canting the thrust and then
I go in the direction so there's a
coupling between attitude and
translation and so what happens is you
come to land on a slope and one leg hits
first and quickly it puts a disturbance
you know it puts a moment of torque on
the vehicle and it moves like this and
so the vehicle starts to go like this if
it goes I don't want to go like that I'm
one of the straight down it turns back
dink-dink again again again and so you
get the skittering sort of happens so
you can try and control that using more
high more quick sensors that that are
very very hair-trigger and do a very
good job of determining it you've just
touched the surface interestingly you
know that mission the Mars Polar Lander
that we lost in 99 and that helped us
remind ourselves about putting Rovers on
top of Landers well when we want of may
be the leading possible cause of the
loss of that mission was that those
triggers those foot pads when we
deployed the legs we came in and on
rockets with the legs tucked in and then
about 80 meters above the surface we
deployed legs
well that one of those those touchdown
sensors triggered during the jerk of
that deployment and the vehicle shut its
engines off and fell the last 80 meters
does that soccer watch there's other
possible causes of course but it's
challenging that legged Lander thing is
challenging because it mean it tends to
drive you to look to take very fast
action very dramatic action at the rise
of a sort of transient signal and one of
the things we love about the sky crane
is the the the sky cranes coming down
the Rovers underneath it's on tethers
you can't push on a rope it comes down
we tell this guy you will go 3/4 in
meter/second down no matter what so the
rover hits the ground this guy goes I
ain't comin it keeps going down and that
says wait a second my throttle settings
are now at half of what they used to be
and we've got little clock Springs that
pull up the slack and so we keep going
down keep going good yeah sure enough I
checked it I checked last second I
checked this second i'ma wait as I say
yeah there's still at the same level
well the only way that could really work
is that the rover is no longer being
held by me it's being held by the
surface of Mars so we're not we're not
sensing that transient event we're
sensing the post-event state of the
vehicle so if that's a persistent thing
we can take all the time in the world it
depends on how long we want to make the
clock Springs and and so we had you know
it's we love that the controllers
involved all the way to the surface
you can come in much slower you can land
what all that really rolls up to meaning
is you can land on very uneven terrain
which is great I imagine when humans go
to Mars they will likely go to places
that are not uneven on treated terrain I
would hope if I were one of those humans
that I'd be going to a place that robots
had been before and they'd taken a
little greater and leveled it out put
some radio beacons maybe written welcome
to Mars on the
you know thing so that we'd reduce the
risk for further human beings so if
that's the case it may not be that human
scale missions also use the sky cream
because then some of the very necessary
or some of the greatest virtues would be
wasted on it and there may be another
strategy that's more mass efficient
under those circumstances I don't know
but in the neighborhood of the masses
that we're talking about for going to to
unknown or uncertain terrain the sky
crane really is pretty cool it would
thank you well it also be then useful
for places like Europe Europe and Titan
Titan that's right that's right all of
those present some slightly different
challenges you lat if you're going to
float a boat are you gonna land on a
sheet of ice
I mean I'll have to go to Europa it
looks like I mean to my eyeball the way
I've vision it envisioned it imagine you
take Manhattan and you knock down all
the buildings but they don't break up so
it's always like chunky huge sheets of
stiff slippery stuff and all sorts of
weird angles and and then there's a big
question for the scientists where do you
want to land on this you want to land on
the side near the top you want when we
down onto the bottom it was a little
crack where we have a really hard time
talking to anybody else because we're at
the bottom of well so at any rate
whether even whether it would be the key
system at Europa I mean maybe not that
depends on where we're going in your
local tense of what the scientists want
but so the fun part about this in 1999
this is a bit ago I was working at JPL
and I had this epiphany
it goes essentially like this we have
visited and remotely sensed almost all
of the objects in the solar system to
one degree or another now we might go
back to get higher res pictures here and
there
do another remote sensing science suite
and there's good reasons to do that but
what we're really entering is the Golden
Age of in situation where I have to go
down and intimately interact with this
unknown environment I'm a mechanical
engineer by heart that means you
mechanically interact
with this environment that is work that
is hard and frequently it's different at
each of the places you might want to go
so it's custom that is cool I mean if
you like doing that kind of stuff which
I do it's pretty good time to be alive
you know I haven't seen you since
basically you were a kid and yeah wait
awhile I was right if I was like 18 or
something like that yeah and you were
not someone that I would have said or
would anyone else that we knew would
have said this guy is going to be a
major planetary exploring engineer yeah
what the hell happened so it ends up
being right yeah I don't really know I
don't really I'm a little too close to
the story to know what the answer to
that is I'm told it a few times I gives
you a bit of a name yeah I does so you
know I think the backstory maybe
everybody knows it but I'll just do the
quick Cliff Notes version I was didn't
do well in school didn't try very hard
in school to defense myself and actually
everybody else that I was not going to
ever apply myself I wasn't that kind of
a guy I was an artist or Rd guy or
whatever not into science or mathematics
or anything I was great boring you were
pretty skateboarding loved skateboarding
loved theater got into music anything
but sort of stuff that required
concentration and focus and applying
oneself and so out of high school I
barely knew that I graduate high school
acts I didn't know that graduate high
school at Tam high where I went in Mill
Valley was high school
give it up Tam hi
thank you
at the time they didn't give out a
diploma when you walked because that was
the era of streaking and they had this
idea that which actually the funniest
part worked that the fear of not getting
your diploma and graduating because you
streaked would stop you from streaking
and it basically it worked but it's
absurd right like [ __ ] you I did the
work
give me my diploma I don't care what I
wore or didn't through the ceremony but
at any rate um so the the the the the
form was you walked and then like the
next day or the following Monday or
something maybe it was over Friday and
the following Monday you wouldn't get
your diploma well I never went back
because I didn't know I thought most
likely it wouldn't be there I had to get
a c-minus or better in John lidey's
environmental chemistry class and I
didn't think I'd done that so didn't go
didn't know when I graduated high school
played rock and roll around the Bay Area
not successfully and I was bored working
in a tell food store in the valley and I
noticed that when I would drive to could
do a show at night the stars were in one
place and when I would drive home they'd
be in a different place why are they
moving
I had clearly not paid attention in high
school enough so it the whole spinning
on its axis that the earth does totally
missed it and even more intriguing I did
not have the logic to notice wait the
Sun does the same
so I went down to the local Community
College College Imran to take an
astronomy course to teach me why the
stars were moving and it had a
prerequisite of a conceptual physics
course and I was like physics in the way
but then conceptual physics it was
physics without math yeah so maybe it
wouldn't it would just be a flesh wound
and and so I gave it a shot and it was a
you know perfect storm of lots of things
my psyche my boredom my willingness to
want to change the pattern of my life
and and this recognition it was a
beautiful sweetly naive recognition of
the time but it's an important one that
there were these rules these laws that
govern the universe and that you could
learn them and you could figure stuff
out like there was a truth an objective
truth it wasn't all just fuzzy and weird
and you could figure it out now I've
come to realize that some of those laws
are just very good models that model a
lot of what we see in the universe but
don't necessarily aren't written you
know written in stone and that we modify
them and add to them as time goes on but
when you're a young student they can be
you know gospel it doesn't matter
whether they're whether they're perfect
or not and so I just dug into that and
at first was really really difficult
because I had not learned how to study
at all I'd gotten mediocre or bad grades
and I was working really hard and
working really hard and not seeing
anything pay off and I was on the bubble
for maybe a semester or two and I can
remember I should have brought it with
me I I should always have it with me I
somewhere in there I was going to take a
calculus course so I I had to start with
elementary algebra trigonometry advanced
algebra and so on I mean I started
really back where my daughter my 11 year
old daughter is doing stuff that I was
learning to do when I was 22 years old
and I but when I got to this place was
not to take a
class needed a scientific calculator
most people hit the wall in calculus I
know this yeah I was it was starting
that was a sort of a snowball starting
to roll downhill and I asked myself
McKeen see reverse polish notation a
really awesome calculator and I said you
know you have like dabbled in so many
different things over the span of your
brief 22 years um are you gonna really
stick with this because it was 83
dollars 83 dollars when you're working
the health food store playing music at
night and you know riding your mountain
bike over the over the hill to to
college Marin is a lot of money I said
I'm gonna stick with it so anyway cool I
did still have that 15 see I don't use
it I use my iPhone but but but I got
good at it and it ends up being though
even though I convinced like therapists
and my parents and myself and every
teacher that I was so not a math guy or
not in this thing but that was kind of
[ __ ] which the great transformative
perhaps teach ibly transformative thing
that I carry for from that experience is
that that may go for everybody in this
room right you may be able to do stuff
that you don't have any clue about doing
if you can get past yourself and find it
so it worked out well it's a great
career for you as a motivational but
going from a bit of calculus and OK at
the physics now you got it why the Stars
moving stuff to be moving on into
becoming a mechanical engineer right
what's that transition ok so stars
physics cool love physics crushing
physics at school I had like gotten
ready to like be an Artie kind of guy
the idea of getting paid and actually
making a regular old Joe living
day-to-day getting up early and just
going
work even though you don't want to had
been abhorrent it and not been really
part of my upbringing and so I had to
fail I decided in that in this part
where I want transformed and changed the
thing that I'm doing I decide to like go
for that and engineering is physics that
you get paid to do you know it's
slightly more practical maybe a little
bit more lowbrow but someone's gonna
actually give you a decent wage and
you'll be able to rent a house and buy
food and that kind stuff so I decided I
have body ray Kronig who was a year
ahead of me if college moran and he went
off to go to engineering school my god
this engineering thing they pay you and
you get to go and so I did it and I
loved it
it had that all the physics except it
was also applied so it was like real
extra real I loved the real of the
universe laws that you could learn and I
really loved the applying it and
actually it worked it didn't break it
worked and oh I'm riding on a bicycle
that I designed that I welded up ooh
that's pretty cool so so yeah ok then
you're starting to be an engineering
happy getting paid to do applied physics
the Cal Tech happen in them JPL yeah so
so I did well in school and I got kind
of into doing well at school kind of
like and I did really really well and so
is this because you were good at it or
you got some motivational heat going or
well both and they self ate each other
so you know I'd been like not applying
myself for my entire life so I don't you
know and also we were like we lived in
England for a little bit when I was kids
and they thought you know in the tiny
little village where we were they
thought we were stupid and then we came
back and they did IQ tests on us to make
sure that we weren't my brother and I
weren't stupid
and so there was done like a lot of like
are they stupid
and and so you know you go through a
little bit of they are you are are you
stupid or are you just unmotivated you
know I was when I was in high school I
was regular high school and actually
interestingly in the sophomore year its
content I'd like to tell stories in
sophomore year I Paul Schwartz Barton
was a tiny little Napoleon of a man
French I think in in in extraction and
was taught French and a couple of other
Romance languages in Latin and for some
weird reason I was taking Latin and I
was late for his class and I knew that
he just pounded on you if you walked in
late to his class so I sat at the edge
of the door of class and I didn't want
to go in
I waited and time went on and I waited a
little longer and time went on and I was
in the bell rang for the next class so I
went to the next class and I was just
sick to my stomach I fought any moment
the door was gonna burst open the
principal's gonna come in there police
officers was terrible but nothing
happened I went through the whole day
and nothing happened so I went back to
the next day gets tired of Latin and I
don't go nothing happened I tried it on
another class
and another one and pretty soon I'm
going to the theater class and nothing
else my sophomore year I have won a and
five FS so the whole question is he
stupid
is he unmotivated they put me in a
special thing where you can take more
classes they tried out the he's
unmotivated so he needs to be more
stimulated given more stuff to do so
then I got like 1a and 7s so the point
being that I had a lot of experience
with the whole question of dumbass are
you unmotivated and so when I started to
taste motivation and started to feel not
so dumb those both sort of turbocharged
each other and I became very into that
into being smart and excellent I like
that sort of double discovery the don't
show up discovery which I did when I
didn't show up for Army Reserve after
two years the army six more years of
stuff back in those days they didn't
come and hunt for you really
it was definitely my life do that and
you know clearly the if you got in
theater took and stood you in probably
good stead for being on camera at
various respects and so on yeah so this
is a tough act to follow they just
showed us yeah
is there another act so so right this is
I have garnered a lot of attention that
happens for many reasons that I can sit
here and those things might help but I
actually believe that there's some
capacity to communicate that's also a
part of it
the but what that sometimes no matter
how hard I try that overshadows is that
it's a you know tremendously large team
effort and actually the greatest most
gratifying piece of this there's a Teddy
Roosevelt quote there's many great Teddy
Roosevelt quotes one of them is that one
of the great prizes that life has to
offer is a chance to work hard at work
worth doing that's a good thing one
that's work worth doing in my book
mm-hmm I have made a riff on that Teddy
quote which goes something like this one
of the great prizes at life has to offer
is that great works require many people
coming together to accomplish them and
it is that community that teamwork that
interaction with others that is also
uniquely human in how we we do this
uniquely human thing that we do so for
me the most gratifying part of this was
working with an incredible team of
people right that had just ideas coming
out of their pores all the time and
sharp instincts and and accurate
analysis I gathered that team of people
together a few minutes before that
happened and I'd done it first about
three months earlier and you know in any
big working environment there's friction
it's a little healthy also but there's
frictions and animosities and so forth I
gathered in three months before landing
and I said look here's the deal
there's our universe ends on the 5th of
August that they're going to enter a
black hole and we're gonna be spit out
into an alternate universe and whether
it's success or failure that universe is
not an extrapolation of the one that
you're sitting in right now
so I want you to look around the room
and I want you to drink this in because
this is gonna be over on the 5th of
August I gathered them again three hours
before landing and I said because we
were all sort of pregnant with a lot you
know I'll do my best
for selfish reasons and for generous
reasons in my life to make something
like this or even more heaven but if it
doesn't this will have been enough
there's a line at the end of the 7
minutes of terror dare mighty things is
that your line Teddy that's Teddy that's
the interesting oh yeah it was no
absolutely it's the I'm gonna try and
bring it give me a second here it's
totally the Panama Canal or something no
no no no no no no it's a it's a it's a
it's a segment of basically valor goes
to the one with the dust in his face
who's broken it's the fighter in the
ring right respect and valour go to the
fighter in the ring the one who's you
know it tried and failed who knows both
perhaps a success and defeat and but
does not know the shallow life of those
who sit on the edge of the ring and
spectate that know neither success or
failure and so it is far better to dare
mighty things and to fail than to never
try and that's where that comes from
I wish I could take credit for
suggesting that that video is an
interesting study in randomness of the
universe the videographer who shot all
of the head shots actually who produced
the whole thing this guy named John Beck
he no longer works at the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory John as a friend
and we had produced videos he had
produced videos over several missions
mostly for the people in the mission
right uh there was a six minutes of
Terror for em er and then there was
another seven minutes of Terror for
something called Phoenix and then a
mission called Phoenix and then for this
we said okay let's make it seven minutes
of Terror and he couldn't get his people
to give him the funding to do it and he
said I'd like to put this one out
publicly and they didn't they weren't
interested so he said to me hey Adam can
we do this over lunch can you come to
the studio and let's try and rough out
some stuff yeah very different ideas as
with any good piece of art it was going
to go on a totally different directions
than it actually went in his image was
inception the movie Inception the
trailer for Inception he showed me the
trailer for Inception it was sort of Sam
Spade II he has a light there you know
we're sort of thinking film noir and
we're doing it in front of green screen
and he thinks he's gonna find some sort
of dark static background as and so we
go through this thing and I do we do the
whole thing and he gives it to his
people and they're like okay you're in
they want it to be all me and because of
the thing that's at fret it's a team and
not singles we eventually pushed in the
rest of the team or small factions resin
team but with the graphics and how and
ends up putting it all together it's a
completely different thing everybody's
like that's pretty cool and they're
still on the bubble about whether they
were gonna release it okay well release
it to YouTube and then come home it's
big deal and it you know the viewership
awareness of curiosity's landing far
outstrips any of our others and it may
well be I think it's to two things
really social media is probably the
biggest the internet in social media
because I was involved in the landing of
spear and opportunity and at that time
there were basically four or five
television stations there were more on
cable but really the world paid
attention to four of them and and they
had nightly news and the nightly news
has gonna tell you five things
and if you're the sixth on that list you
didn't happen and so we were in the top
of those lists or in the five for like
the first three days oh and then Britney
Spears got out of limousine not wearing
something and all of a sudden we are
number six and we were fell off the
radar so I'm here this time it
distributed information processing so
you think it's funny or interesting or
cool you tell him who tells her who
tells those three and it all can happen
without these sort of choke points of
the conduits so I think that's a big
deal and maybe this thing helped the
seven myths of Tara may have helped that
Chum the water before then I say no
question you ended your talk kind of
promptly saying that space-exploration
all of this outward stuff is impractical
but tells us something about ourselves
and is telling us something about the
questions we care about and you're also
suggesting that the skills that were
thinking about going outward go back
right now I have a history with this
mirror effect which is back when I said
you know we're looking to go to the moon
with all these photographs of the moon
and all this stuff going out and
nothing's turning back to photograph
reverse and I said hey come on do it ten
years after Sputnik went up and that's
you know twelve years after it went up
by the way yeah there you go
and there were photographs of earth and
indeed it did change our perception of
ourselves so that mirror is real I've
seen it what do you think is the in a
sense the future of that mirror of the
reflection we're getting on ourselves
from the spatial exploration Wow I don't
know how to answer that
I think while you're thinking you
started to say that it's a cop-out to
think of space colonies or somehow
colonizing and terraforming Mars would
be some sort of solution to earth
problems because if we could do that we
could you know the earth problems
wouldn't need to be solved because we've
been some of them here right with those
skills that's right so that's part of it
but well there's so there's a set right
so to that point there's a set of risks
that with threats to humanity right um
internal and external we're doing a
pretty good job I think now I mean
there's some external it may just come
in and just wipe us out I mean you could
argue that we should just tribute
ourselves across the stars to make sure
that it doesn't happen I think the odds
of that happening are relatively small
the external thing coming in and getting
us here here and unless is we're
learning how to one of our previous
speakers had Lulu said you know we can
identify the threatening asteroids not
the Commons but the asteroid to select
them right and so so you know the risks
are relatively low I think that the
risks are highest from ourselves
internally and so really my push is to
not think that well by the way in
terraforming Mars I mean that's involved
right you have to have an understanding
of how to balance we you have to have an
understanding if they have to push us an
ecosystem in an entirely huge direction
and have it find another equilibrium
point right of that may exist for me not
I don't know but that that means that
seat is tremendous and if we can do that
then you know there are what are we
doing here that we can't get on get in
control and there's a there's a there's
a piece of it also about the appetite
you know I'm a man of very many
appetites and big appetites so I'm this
is hypocrisy never stops me
you know but eventually I mean I hope
that they're not reason that we don't
think we need to go outside because we
can't we must keep growing but we must
be more people or more that arguments
kind of gone away as nearly I hope
because that's not a great argument
right and so it's something that we're
doing wrong and if the places that we
would be going to a world ship that we
design the ecosystem and set it up in
perfect harmony and it doesn't go wrong
well we co-evolved with an ecosystem
right here that's some pretty good I
mean even though we beat the crap out of
it it does pretty good for us so it's I
don't think our solutions are out there
that was my the the main push that I was
trying to make that mirror for me just
makes me underscores how precious and
unique in the space that we can touch in
millennia this place is you know the the
photograph of Earth from space they've
got people there's sort of two one is
the you know and the Sun is behind the
camera and they see a full dry scan
that's what people imagine is the whole
earth it just happens to be of a version
of Earth it's not a crescent right but
the one that really got people was the
so called Earthrise yeah I because the
earth never rises over the my stationery
in the sky but you're rising of the
satellites going around and over the
land the moon comes the earth they take
photograph in the video and what people
see is a small a great big dead
foreground yes
Nevada on a bad day yep and this tiny
little of quite undeniably beautiful
blue complicated marble even leaving a
fragile looking thing that contrasts
seems to have been what got people and
by the way as part of what people are
getting from the movie gravity which
says right at the beginning in space
life is impossible
basically is one of the sort of the
captions that kind of throws the
beginning and then you spend the rest of
the movie discovering how extremely
impossible life is in space not inside
all this incredible grinding absolutely
so part of the bounce then is in the
sense seeing life in contrast to death
well when yes look when we I'm working
now I'm leading the effort to develop a
system that will extract core samples
from of rocks from Mars down past that
five centimeter depth seal them
specially individually in a cache that
could conceivably be returned by another
vehicle at a later time we're gonna
spend a lot of time and effort doing
that we're sort of scratching at is
there life on Mars you know it looks
pretty dead if there's life it's
bacterial it spawns coming by earth
standards it doesn't look very alive
right you go out to the center of Mojave
Desert where there's nobody and it's
teeming with life compared to what we
look at on Mars so that's the thing that
I'm struck by is holy crap we're
swimming in this warm pool of loving
life and that is very very rare you know
when we go out looking for it and the
rest of our solar system and certainly
even when we go out looking we are
finding thousands of planets around
other stars or we will find thousands we
may be up to thousands already it
happened so quickly I can't keep track
but of those you know there are a few
that are you know we aren't finding in a
it's not that on the numbers in the
Drake Equation I think there's a lot of
them but they are still very rare and
and so that's the that's my experience
of that mirror as I go out as I design
as I help and people design spacecraft
to go to these places that we build them
to live with in these harsh environments
um doesn't feel friendly and it does not
look like this place so that's my big
experience of what I think is out there
now because all we understand are the
laws that do a good job explaining the
world around us the universe around us
in this vicinity of us there may well be
dimensions or ways of travel that blow
out my conception of the universe and so
going major places in a human lifespan
yeah that's actually very interesting as
other stars yes let's talk about that
for very brief time so I so we work on
developing space projects projects to go
explore space there are some very
interesting time constants associated
with that process there are things like
four years or eight years or 20 years
what's 20 years 20 years is like the
active career lifetime of a human being
so a person who is an advocate to do a
thing is there and holding sway on that
for order 20 years if you have a mission
that is a 40 year mission the person who
starts it is not going to be the person
who finishes it and it's continuity
across that vision of what it is is
difficult so when our expeditions go out
many human time constants it gets very
hard for it requires a very different
set and very long thinking long thinking
in a way that is unusual in us because
it's way outside the time cycle of our
lives so anyway that's interesting to me
and I think it's a slight challenge that
projects that are many many many many
human
lifetime constants in length face like
we can take thank the space program and
you for helping us think in those many
generations and by the way showing us
that there's life on earth thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you